so now we come to a interesting variant
of ordinary induction called strong
induction and here's how it works
strong induction just as with ordinary
induction you prove the base case P of 0
you're trying to prove for all N P of n
so you prove P of 0 but now in order to
prove P of n plus 1 in the inductive
step assuming P of N with ordinary
induction with strong induction you can
assume not just P of n but you can
assume P of 0 P of 1 all of the
properties that all the numbers up
through n have the property and from
this of course you could conclude that
for that everything has the property
that for all N P of M now an intuitive
way to justify this is you think about
it the way the induction works is you
start off at 0 and then you make a step
to 1 and you make another step to 2 and
you make another step to 3 and the
induction step going from n to n plus 1
justifies each of those steps by the
time you get to N and you have to prove
you can get to n plus 1
you've already been through 0 1 up to n
you might as well take advantage of that
fact instead of only remembering that
you're at the end step you might as well
remember that you got there that's an
intuitive hand-wavy argument which can
be justified formally in a way that will
emerge in the next segment so let's hold
off on that and just bite the bullet and
accept this as a basic principle of math
that we're gonna live with and use all
right as an application of it let's
prove something that we've already
proved by well ordering in fact strong
induction well ordering are closely
related as will also discuss later so
let's prove that using 3 & 5 cent stamps
that you can get any amount of postage
greater than or equal to 8 cent stamps
and I'm gonna prove this by strong
induction with the induction hypothesis
P of n that says I can form n plus 8
cent stamps clearly if I can prove for
all n P of n then I've proved that I can
get for every amount greater
equal to 8 cent stamps and let's do the
base case well the base case P of 0 can
I make 8 cent stamps sure 3 & 5 that's
that one and that's okay for the
inductive step I have to get aa M I'm
allowed to assume rather that I can get
M plus 8 cents for any M from n down to
zero instead of just assuming that I can
get n plus 8 cents to get n plus 1 plus
8 cents I can assume any amount less
than what I'm aiming for so I may as
well assume that I can get any amount of
postage from 8 up to n plus 8 cents and
my objective then is to get n plus 1
plus 8 cents namely and plus 9 cents so
I have to prove that for all N greater
than or equal to 0 I can get n plus 9
cents
assuming I can get from 8 to n plus 8
cents well it's not too hard to do the
inductive step is actually going to
break up into a couple of cases
depending on other value event have to
prove n plus 9 cents for all n so
suppose N equals zero I have to get 9
cents
well three threes if n is one I have to
get one plus nine cents or ten cents two
fives so those cases are disposed of so
now my job is to get n plus nine cents
where n is greater than or equal to two
well the nice thing about n being
greater than or equal to two is that if
I subtract two from it it's a smaller
number and it's still non-negative and
that means that I can get that amount
plus eight cent stamps so I'm in this
nice situation where I buy strong
induction I can get n minus two plus
eight cents dance there they are and how
do I get 2n plus nine well it's easier
at a 3-cent stamp and you have n plus
nine cents which completes the proof of
the induction case and the whole theorem
is proved
we can conclude then that it works for
all n and that you can indeed get n plus
eight cents using three and five cent
stands for all of them so much for that
example alright let's look at another
example this is a game that we used to
play in class you start off with a stack
of blocks say ten blocks and you're
allowed to make a move that consists of
splitting the stack into two smaller
stacks so if the stack has height a plus
B you can split it into a stack of
height a and a stack of height B and you
get a score for that move the score is 8
times B and then you keep doing that
until you can't make any more moves that
is when all you have left our stacks of
height 1 which you can't split anymore
and then your overall score is the total
that you got for all the moves that you
made until that point now when we played
this in class we would have students
competing and they would try various
strategies so one strategy the the
simplest strategy maybe not the best but
the simplest strategy would be you start
off with a stack of 10 so you take one
off and that leaves you with a stack of
1 and 9 your score is 9 then you take
another one off of the stack of 9 and
you're left with a 1 and an 8 your score
is 8 and so on and you can see in fact
if you took the one-at-a-time
process then your score with a stack of
hide n would be n minus 1 plus n minus 2
Delta 2 plus 1 another strategy that
might be sort of more in the spirit of
computer science would be to keep
splitting in two
so for example if you had a stack of
height n you can split it into two fives
and then you take one of the fives and
split it into a three and a two and then
you'd split the two into two ones and so
on splitting as evenly as you can each
time and it seems like it might be a
better strategy and again we would have
students try various strategies and
guess what they all came in in a tie and
that's what we're going to prove now
every way of unstacking end blocks gives
the same score well what's
score well we know that the score for
the simple strategy of taking one block
off at a time is this sum from 1 to n
minus 1 and that has a nice formula n
times n minus 1 over 2 so we can
formulate our claim that no matter how
you play the unstacking game with a
stack of size n your final score will be
n times n minus 1 over 2 and we're going
to prove this by strong induction with
this statement called a claim of n is
going to be the induction hypothesis
that's what we're trying to prove well
let's start in the usual way the base
case is N equals 0 well you might be
bothered that's no blocks well let's see
what happens with no blocks the score is
0 because there's nothing to do and
indeed the formula that is alleged to be
your score comes out to be 0 so in the
base case N equals 0 works let's
continue for the inductive case I have
to assume that the given score formula
holds for all stacks of height and or
less and I have to prove that it holds
for a stack of height n plus 1 that is
that an N plus 1 stack score is n plus 1
times n over 2 well how shall I do that
well I'm gonna split the inductive case
into two cases it turns out that I need
to prove that C of n plus 1 holds
assuming C of n fir and less than n but
in particular let's just deal with the
case that n plus 1 is 1 the smallest
value it could have and knock that one
off separately namely if the stack is of
height 1 again my score is zero because
there's no move to make and the formula
still evaluates to 0 so in the case that
n plus 1 is 1 I've proved the claim at n
plus 1 which I was obligated to do for
the base case for the inductive step
well the other case in the inductive
step is that n plus 1 is greater than 1
this is the interesting one because now
it's possible to make a move so since n
plus 1 is greater than 1 it's 2 or more
blocks I can make a move into 2 stacks
that are both of positive size so
suppose I do
that suppose I split the stack of size n
plus one into an a stack and a b stack
where a and b sum to n plus 1 and what's
my score gonna be then well my score on
that move that I make where I split into
the a stack and the B stack is a B and
the rest of the game consists of playing
as well as I can on the a stack and as
well as I can on the B stack but a and B
is smaller than n plus 1 they're less
than or equal to n which means that by
strong induction I know that no matter
how I play on the a stack I'm gonna wind
up with this score a times a minus 1
over 2 no matter how I play on the B
stack I'm gonna wind up with B times B
minus 1 over 2 so that means that my
score on the a plus B stack is gonna be
this form to let a be Plus 8 times 8
minus 1 over 2 plus B times B minus 1
over 2 so you simplify that into to
organize it so it's a plus B times a
plus B minus 1 which is exactly n plus 1
times n over 2 which is what we were
trying to prove we've proved C of n plus
1 the inductive step is complete and
indeed we've proved that no matter how
big the stack is your score comes out
the same